hello everyone and welcome to our
wonderful webinar today this is Dan
Buettner and I'm your host for today and
Robert lasers will be joining us in just
a moment this webinar is going to be
about how to improve course completion
and certification rates so let's talk a
little bit about your hosts here and we
are simply learned now the wonderful
thing about simply learned is that we're
the most credible training provider for
the digital age so founded in 2009 since
the learn is one of the world's largest
and leading providers of online training
for digital marketing cloud computing
project management data science IT
software development and many other
emerging technologies we're based in
Bangalore India and also San Francisco
California we've helped over 500,000
professionals and companies across 150
countries get trained require
certifications and up skill their
employees our 400 training courses are
designed and updated by world class and
world leading industry experts so the
wonderful thing about our approach is
that we have a blended learning approach
that combines eLearning
classes instructor led live virtual
classrooms applied learning projects
24/7 teaching assistants so we have more
than 40 global training organizations
that have recognized simply learned as
an official provider of certification
training and we've also been named the
eighth most influential education brand
in the world by LinkedIn these are just
some of the statistics about simple
learn and with this background we have a
lot of experience in helping people get
certified and trained and completing
that training and now we're going to be
able to share some of these statistics
with you so again for how to improve
course completion of certification rates
welcome I'm Dan bavander and Robert how
are you great how come
everybody good afternoon or good morning
everyone I hope everyone's having a
great day to give you a little bit of
background about myself
I'm currently I'm the director of
customer success that simply learned in
the u.s. so I am based out of San
Francisco but my background is a lot of
Education I have a lot to do with
teaching and instruction name completion
because I was a former K through 12
principal I also was a teacher of the
dean of students and I also currently a
magic instructor for a university where
I teach masters courses and Technology
teacher leadership and curriculum and
construction so I am I have a little bit
of background knowledge on what it's
like to want to make sure that we were
getting hundred percent completion or at
least some great usage out of our
courses when we're working with our
learners great well thank you Robert and
I am Dave Evander and I'm the the an
instructor-led an e-learning curriculum
developer and presenter and I'm the
director of content marketing here at
simply learned as well as the director
of training research and I've come
across a lot of information about not
only what helps us improve our could be
completion rates but what helps other
online courses from universities and
business business trainers train their
people well as well so I have 15 years
of experience in teaching and developing
curricula we're including instructor-led
training and video based eLearning and
I'm certifying an additional marketing
numerous other skills including aviation
I'm a pilot and also other high-tech
endeavors in the aviation field
including avionics so that's just a
little bit about me but you are here to
learn how you can improve your
completion rates because you invest so
much money in your alerting and
development and how do you ensure that
your employees are actually finishing
the training because just because you
build it doesn't mean that they will
come research shows that the typical
completion rates for online courses can
be as low as 4% now whether your goal is
to get your employees to learn new job
skills or to get them certified
maximizing your return on investment
depends on employees not just
participating in training but finishing
it so this is what we're going to be
sharing with you today sharing the
current research on how to improve
training completion rates especially
when it comes to online courses another
learning programs the methods that were
going to describe here include technique
setup help some training programs
achieve completion rates including
simply learns up as high as 72 percent
well let's talk a bit now about what
we're gonna talk about first of all we
want to talk about course completion why
does it matter what does it matter to
your business also going to talk about
the five top reasons why employees fail
to complete the training we're also
going to show you how to spot pip fails
in your pitfalls in your training
program before they become real issues
that are hampering your completion rates
then finally and this is what you're all
here for sure is to discover the proven
ways to improve completion of training
and certifications so moving ahead let's
just give a little overview of your
questions here now we have a moderator
that's going to be monitoring our chat
and also our questions those of you that
have not been on a webinar before just
familiarize yourself with the control
panel here you can maximize it or
minimize it as you like by pressing that
red arrow and the little plus signs that
you have down on the side of your menu
there can expand a little box that will
help you ask questions feel free to ask
questions as you go on and then those
will be shared with us as we're talking
and we'll take a break a little few few
minutes in here and answer questions
then I've come up and then we'll do that
again at the end so again you're all
muted so feel free to type in your
questions and we have a lot of people
here to help you so moving on the first
person that is here to help you is
Robert Lizzie's so tell us a little bit
about why completion matters so I think
the one thing that people learn to
really consider is what are they trying
to get out of any sort of training that
they're gonna do and and the impression
is a really important part of getting
that goal of what you're looking to
accomplish but what we need to find out
is you know in terms of a company is
there something more than just
completion that really is going to
matter so one thing we found that most
companies invest in training in order to
achieve real improvement in skill and
practice but we're also finding that
organizations with a strong Learning and
Development Program are 56 percent more
likely to be fir
to market and 17% more profitable than
their peers and that's extremely
important to note because having a goal
and having a program in mind is really
what's gonna make it successful you know
some situations make it a hundred
percent necessary for completion and in
that case when training or certification
is part of the corporate directive or a
government mandate common in higher
regulated industries like banking health
care and insurance you're gonna see that
this is going to be a mandate it's gonna
be expected for example if you're
looking at the there's a new law for
program management improvement and
accountability yet act and so that's
telling us that if we are gonna have
anybody that's working in those courses
they have to have a hundred percent
completion we need them so that they can
be certified same with the ethics
awareness act as well as IT security
awareness Act so if you are a company
that's looking to certify your learner's
this is a specific reason why we see a
lot of people come across simply learn
in terms of wanting to make sure that
they have a hundred percent completion
for certification so that they can use
that in it when I say use it I think
it's important to note that if you are
actually going to be having that kind of
certification there are reasons for that
certification excuse me the Society of
corporate compliance and ethics and NYC
s key governance services found that
although ninety six percent of
organizations surveyed offer some kind
of ethics and compliance training twelve
percent failed to achieve completion for
mandatory code training and twenty six
failed to complete risk training and
that's important especially if you are
I'm gonna be mandated by law however
there are benefits to I'm sorry go ahead
in oh I was just gonna say that's it's
amazing that that a full quarter of
people in industries that actually
require this training certification
don't even complete the training
exactly which is you know in one sense
may be a little bit scary in the end the
fact that it is a requirement and we
don't have people finishing it so I
think having that program is what's
gonna be necessary but to be honest with
you Dan outside of just making sure that
your your learner's are getting
certified for the let's say the law for
it there are a ton of other benefits to
making sure that your learner's are
certified for example it's gonna
validate your employees expertise to
co-workers and customers and I think
that's important to be able to highlight
you have X number of learners that are
certified analyst a program management
or ethics awareness I think that's
really important and it also you know in
reality can increase potential company
revenue by justifying to the client a
higher billing rate because they have so
many people that are certified and also
in in that sense as well eliminates real
reliance and outside contractors because
a lot of the work can be done internally
if we have these people that have this
certification and I think that's really
important to note as well right that's a
great point now what's funny about that
is that just because companies meet the
completion and certification directors
now there's no guarantee that employees
will actually remember and apply what
they've learned to the job and I know
this is particularly true if the
training is acquired hastily so there
was a great quote that I saw and it was
by a Sherman House Krishna way who said
that a hundred percent course completion
is a great first step in meeting the
business objectives however completion
has been no means a reflection of the
usefulness of the course there was a
study of learners at companies with more
than 5,000 employees and revealed that
as few as nine percent of trained
employees actually applied what they've
learned to their job to achieve positive
results now in some cases course
completion isn't critical to business
objectives for example if employees are
able to demonstrate and apply those
necessary skills even before the
completion of the full course then that
may be enough for example the training
gained in the first few units per unit
the in the first few units of like a
cybersecurity certification of course
you know that may be enough to help
people fix an organization's key
vulnerability another real example is at
a PMP training 90% of people who
complete the training do not actually go
ahead and take the PMP certification
exam the main reason for that is because
the cost of the exam is like five
hundred dollars and in some cases even
more expensive so just because it isn't
completed doesn't mean they haven't
learned something but the more you can
get people past that finish line the
better
now Bob tell us a bit about why people
fail to complete the training what are
the big Hang Ups so Dan is funny because
we talk about the fact that there are
you know regulations and laws for
certain types of training and had a
percent completion but you also
mentioned a few stats and as I did that
there are areas where people just aren't
getting it done and so I will say that
no matter how much we have a drive for
it there are gonna be things like get in
the way let's take for example you see
these 17 this gives me these seven
reasons here of course to intensive time
constraints lack of motivation if you
think about these for example course to
intensive there are a lot of times where
we actually give a lot of educational
materials and concepts and that are
required but it's just too intensive for
someone to understand this may be over
their head maybe the course is too
advanced for the specific trainees and
this also can be due to newness of the
or complexity of the nature of the
subject matter itself and we may be
giving employees concepts or topics that
we think that they're ready for and they
might not be and that can be a really
quick turn off and employees could end
up failing that training
I'm the other piece I think we sometimes
forget and they like to think about our
time constraints this is really
important because as managers we often
know you know we're busy and we know
that our learners are gonna be very busy
as well but sometimes we forget exactly
how busy they are because in life you've
got work going on but once they leave
work they went if family they might have
friends they might have things that they
have to be working on outside of work as
well and so sometimes that can actually
cost trainers are the trainees not to
succeed because there are too many
things that are happening and without a
great build in in terms of a schedule
sometimes it's just not going to be
successful another thing that I think is
gonna be is sort of tricky to be honest
with you is lack of motivation and I
think that goes with the no management
support as well you know a lot of times
if we're not giving the learners this
this feeling or this push to want to get
this training done and really give them
get them ramped up we're gonna find that
sometimes they're just not going to be
as invest in it and really what cannot
make that happen is management support
having your manager of being able to
know what the training is about know why
we're doing the training and maybe even
do some incentives that are in there
that may really help bring that you know
knowledge and
and excitement towards it that wouldn't
be there otherwise and I think that's
one thing that we want to make sure we
watch for the rest of them is things
like technology downtime we can't ours
control but we have to consider right
sometimes we lose Wi-Fi if we're working
on e-learning and those things are
important as well as for course design
occasionally we'll have learners jump
into something that hasn't quite been
vetted well and then that's the case we
can actually be giving them a really
negative experience and really turn them
off because the course itself may not be
in you know may may not actually be
suited for them at any at any points and
the last one Dan I'm not gonna like kind
of as the most common yet and my most
favorite comment about it it's forgot
about the course and I hate to say it
but there's a million things that people
are doing so sometimes they do well yeah
that's true and I hear that most people
the only the only type of management
support that they get is an email
reminder and 71 percent of the time that
the only thing that prompts people to
complete the training is they get an
email saying time to train or did you
finish your training yeah exactly well
there's a helpful sometimes they they
get pushed to the bottom of the pile
because time constraints and things like
that that happen on a daily job and so
they really do just sometimes forget
about it unfortunately yeah well when
those things happen it's important to
recognize when they're when those
problems are coming down the pike and so
let's talk a bit about how to spot those
problems before they really impact our
training now the surprising thing about
poor completion rates is that they very
often come as a surprise the ongoing
nature of training provides many can
continues opportunities to recognize
these issues in time to get the
employees training back on track now one
of the ways you can do this is to get
periodic feedback during the course if
you want to know how employers are taken
to the training just ask them those of
you that are familiar with the
Kirkpatrick scale it's a four level
scale of measuring the way of measuring
the effectiveness of the training the
very first level is to ask the employees
ask the trainees how the training is
going now the best way to do these is
you can do them from
or brief questionnaires you can just
have informal conversations by the water
cooler or you can actually have short
interviews with participants and get
down to the root of how the training is
going and this really kind of helps you
determine the quality of the instructor
or the quality material get get a good
idea of at the very surface level of the
training quality if you want to get more
serious some people with large companies
actually have focus group sessions with
all the participants together at once to
get an idea of the course before they
invest too much time going through
something that may be having a problem
such as this is where you can get an
early pulse on such things as equipment
problems maybe the people are having
bandwidth resources or if they're having
to work at home they may not have the
same type of computer hardware that is
enabling them to do the e-learning and
you can solve those problems nip that in
the bud and the way to do that is get
feedback at the front the other thing
you can do is do assessments now a lot
of simply learning courses we have pre
assessment because it particular you
need in the digital marketing sphere and
a pretest for placement is one way that
you can really help people complete the
training because they can give them the
opportunity to for one thing test out
give them an option to test out of
specific courses that they don't need so
that they aren't bored and then they
give up on the training and don't get
some material that was really useful for
them at the same time you want to make
sure that you bring everybody up to
speed because not everyone comes in to
something with the same knowledge
background like ITIL or any sort of
computer software training a lot of
people may need to get up to square two
where everybody else is so with that pre
testing you can kind of get some
remedial training in there ahead of time
that so everyone can can start in the
meat of it at the beginning I mean start
in the meat of it together this is
really useful particularly for your
doing anything like a live virtual class
or particularly instructor-led classroom
training that's set on the takes a large
investment and you want to make sure
that you're maximizing
everyone's participation in their class
so that everyone's speed at the at the
beginning the other way you can do that
is through intermediate quizzes as
they're taking the training give them a
quiz and find out you know how are you
doing and what's interesting is that is
that pre assessment does more than
provide companies with an honest
snapshot of their team's actual skills
beforehand it actually provides a
comparative tool to measure training
results and then point out any needs for
remedial refresher training so about the
quizzes those are great because they can
even improve learners long term
recollection and retention of the
material the other thing you can do to
help the with completion rates is to
monitor the training as is going on with
dashboards now the best training
solution is include or integrate with
the learning management system or LMS a
good LMS includes dashboards that allow
managers and trainees to see the
assigned and completed training modules
measure that progress towards your goal
and to exchange feedback about the
course as it's going on the tools like
LMS dashboards and custom portals also
enable managers to monitor who's
advancing through the training and who's
lagging behind now the mask can show you
that when the learners have last logged
on or when they've posted a contribution
or maybe completed a quiz it's nice
because it lets managers report to
executives on the effectiveness of the
training even while it's underway so you
don't need to do a measurement right at
the end you can say hey if this is how
it's going and it eliminates the
unwelcome surprises and continuously
motivates your learners which is really
important is it addresses that
motivation aspect we just talked about
and it improves completion
recertification rates by monitoring and
motivation so now let's talk a bit about
how to actually improve certification
this is where you should all be taking
notes because this is by the way taking
you apart this recorded webinar will be
shared with everyone who's attending so
we will also have the slide deck to
review these details and we have a nice
white paper
that we can send afterwards to to sum up
all these great techniques so Bob let's
dive in to how to improve these
completion rates sure first of all when
it comes to keeping it short split it up
the keywords gonna be chunking you know
time constraints and limited attention
span of both major barriers that can be
overcome by delivering training using
shorter lessons so chunking is a popular
learning strategy that improves you know
comprehension and retention of long
strings information because it divides
it up into smaller units or chunks and
that's easier to process and commit to
memory which I think a lot of times we
want to get a lot of information out and
we forget that if we do it in smaller
pieces
well actually end up giving people
something they can really walk away with
you know the problem is that many
employees kind of feel overwhelmed with
how they will undergo training while
carrying out their everyday job
responsibilities which we were talking
about earlier is why people tend to fall
short a better approach to assignment no
more than two courses two allurement at
one time that was suggested by a
corporate training expert Robin McNab
McDermott because as courses are
completed new courses can be added
tasking learners with doable assignments
and they're not overwhelmed with what
they're working on and that's really
important the other thing to consider is
being able to split some stuff up so if
you have longer courses split them into
pieces
you know like level one and then level
two it's it makes things a little bit
easier for people to grasp and creating
shorter lectures like two to seven
minutes is ideal and that's actually
something we currently do and simply
learn is we want to make it so that the
learning that you're looking at is
something that you can take in small
bites because you know to be honest with
you Dan most people are doing a million
things at the same time and the hard
part is how do you balance it all so if
you're working let's say 10 minutes on
the course you could probably get
through two videos or a video and you
can move on to something else
it's a gradual way to be able to bring
that learning it's your regular life
because there's a million other things
that you're doing
yeah that's certainly better than like
trying to do one 10 hour course which no
one has really timed it to fit into
their into their schedule particularly
if they're trying to do a learning at
home that's a huge piece of it it's the
fact that people are doing elearning at
home they're doing it on their commute
they're doing it really quick while
they're making dinner or while the kids
are brushing their teeth any learning
happens in so many different random
places that be able to make them
a bit shorter is to make it more
realistic yeah that's great so another
cool thing is that it gives them that
that short-term goal to help because if
you if you complete something in the
short term then you think oh I've
accomplished something versus this huge
daunting chunk of learning that you have
to do right the beginning well I'm like
you were saying if you were to have
let's say an entire you know 10 hour
course I have a feeling that you would
or 10 one-hour courses the difference
between the two is how much you really
can remember right if you've got a
shorter a course you feel like you as
you said accomplished a few things and
gone somewhere if it's a really long
course with no breaks people are going
to forget where they started where they
ended with they're working on and then
it sort of becomes you know a fruitless
amount of time spent yeah it's also when
you break it up I know that it also has
the advantage of that you can test
people out of those chunks so rather
than saying starting people at a point
in the course where they they know too
much and they're bored with it you can
test out of the first two introductory
lessons or the four or maybe even split
it up among employees is to say if you
if you're doing digital marketing for
example and you have someone that
doesn't really need to know about SEO
because that's done by the web
department you they can skip out of that
one or they can test out of it and by
having and then chunks that makes it
easier to make it more efficient for
everyone and plus it gives you the
opportunity to do quizzes and reward
progress a lot more often and then I
think the final issue of that is that
when you break things up in chunks it's
a lot easier on the bandwidth so those
people that are having technology issues
if you have a small course is a lot
easier to watch it on your phone or on
your mobile device and and it it doesn't
get as clunky and you don't have to
start for the beginning ganthet
sometimes people forget to because if
you're downloading something before you
jump on train or or a bus it's if it's a
smaller piece it's actually gonna be
much easier to download and much easier
to to be able to work with so you
hundred percent agree yeah what else
you're talking about management support
before and how important that is
what [ __ ] managers help improve this
completion so this is I think one of the
key aspects of it so if you want
employees to value that's training it's
essential to create and foster a
top-down learning culture where the
management actually values a training so
priority prioritizing training is a
single biggest way to improve completion
rates for employees
that's what GERD skilling says he's a
project manager at vintage path and I
think that's something to note is that
when the employees feel that they're
being supported by a manager who
understands what they're going through I
think they actually feel like they're
it's more part of the team and that's I
think really important in terms of being
will get things accomplished whether
it's completion or just getting some
understanding they're just the
organization should understand training
goals as a whole
that means the management all the way
down to the learners because those need
to be can made excuse-me communicated to
the employees these managerial actions
help to ensure the training is valuable
to the learner and is fully aligned with
business goals and the conversation
expectation setting prepares the
learners for actual training event and
that's where they feel like there is
going to be a reason for the training if
you want great ROI on your training you
need to make sure that you are
explaining why the training is important
and you mean to make sure that everyone
sees the value of why the company is
putting money into training for its
employees that's right yeah you know I
know I know there are some cases where
the training is actually compulsory so
we're training is closely related to
your job skills and it's even required
by like certification requirements we
were talking before there's no real
problem with completion rates when you
make it a part of the job but that's not
something that every company can do but
one thing you can do I know is explain
the importance of the training and do
this before the training begins say this
is how it's going to help you this is
why we need it and then also just tell
them what they can expect to learn for
the course and and how it's going to
help them in their daily job performance
too what's another thing managers can
help do to make it easy you know Dan we
talked about a little bit earlier it's
that dedicating the training time so I
have actually seen the clients do some
really crazy and innovative things in
the sense
Sene you know lunch alerts where
everyone gets to learn together at that
exact same time one day a week I've seen
people do where it's the no-collar where
they don't get to they don't get any
emails they don't get any calls for an
hour once a week and they dedicate their
time for training I've seen people do
you know pizza lunches where everyone
gets together and they do the training
together as long as if the manager is
building some time into the schedule I
think people are gonna actually really
value that training because they're
gonna see it's important enough to be
able to take up some other time during
the day that's really important but I'm
also going to tell you that if you do
something like that it's also important
for people in the company to know so you
need to make sure that all supervisors
are informed of that training especially
if there's gonna be some time allotted
for it you want to make sure that
everyone's on that same page so that
doesn't make anything difficult for the
learners that are in it right yeah I
know there's some times that a lot of
employees will want to sit down to do
some training and then all of a sudden
there's a there's a big fire drill and
some project comes in that needs to get
done and that training needs to be shown
as it's a priority and one thing you can
do is to establish a training a manager
and mentor not only does that kind of
create an insulation between your
employees and any sort of executives
that may want to interrupt that training
time but also to oversee the training
activities and note the progress and the
certification and they can report that
to stakeholders it's also cool to
actually have the managers take the
pre-assessment test or have the managers
take some of the training so they have
some idea of what the experience is like
from the learners perspective that will
help understanding a lot plus you know
it'll make it'll build that respect of
the trainees for the management as well
and everyone benefits from that you know
what Dan is I had a client of a major
marketing company actually in New York
that what the the CMO actually went
through the training and was able to
speak to it you know occasionally you go
throw it out this is why it's important
everyone should do this but they were
actually speaking to the training that
the learners were going through
and you could see when they were doing
some roundtable discussion that when he
was having a conversation people kept oh
you really you did go through this you
know what we're going through you took
the test it was interesting to see
people's reaction and they were getting
more invested because they felt like
they're a part of that core team that
we're doing that was doing the training
right yeah that's true
and I think we'll talk about that later
is that it builds that camaraderie with
your other learners when you know this
is an important progress it kind of
makes it like an the it's a really
bonding experience to kind of go through
this initiation of learning because then
it's a it kind of gives you the same
sort of a feeling of belonging is
learning to like a little school you or
belonging to university and like you
know go team everybody as I think I
think education and certification is
there like a great part of employee
team-building and that's it's a much
more important than just the massages or
or or or golf golf lessons or outings at
the dodgeball game well and you know
what you've set up a bring or you bring
up a really great point too because it's
really great for the managers to start
to recognize the learners for their
training in the progress and I think we
you know often get wrapped up in all
these projects and trying to get things
done by deadlines but sometimes we
forget that our learners are there any
need to acknowledge the work that
they're doing and that's really
important so I think being able to give
them that bracelet pat on the back to
say hey you did a great job you've
completed this lesson you completed this
course whatever they might look like is
important to do and you know in some
respects you can also even tie to their
individual goals or KPIs by being able
to say these are the things that we'd
like to have accomplished in this given
amount of time whether it's an or an
annual review or anything like that by
being able to do those virtual Pat's on
the back as you're going through the
courses it really does have come to a
larger summation that when you're doing
your annual review yeah that's a good
point you know a lot of companies are
particularly companies that are focused
on the services aspect that may not be
piece work oriented where sometimes
there's it's it's helpful to have a
quantifiable KPI that you
used to measure your job performance
because a lot of it particularly in
marketing is very subjective and the
nice thing about training is that if you
go through it then that's like something
that everyone can look at and go yes I
did that and that's that makes me a much
more valuable employee and yeah
everybody benefits from that so what
else can we do there's we talked a
little bit about testing out of it and I
think it relates to this relevancy
problem if you want to make training
easier to complete make it relevant to
every employee as the problem is that
when you've got training this generic it
dilutes the relevance to the workplace
and it leaves them wondering oh how is
this related me and my job because you
can improve their completion rates by
enforcing course relevance in a number
of ways for example you can choose or
design the courses specifically for each
team or employee like assignments if
you're doing simply learn does a lot of
applied learning projects and one of
things we do with that is that we have
specific assignment scenarios or
role-playing work and that works best
when it's specifically based on the job
that individual performs and you can
even white label stuff so that you're
using doing case studies that are
related to your industry and even your
own company and that really helps
demonstrate their relevancy if were you
doing pre assessments also help
demonstrate the knowledge gaps and
remind people oh maybe I don't know it
all maybe I I am lacking some
cybersecurity education here I did not
know about didn't know so much about the
Internet of Things and how they can
affect my my cybersecurity and by
letting people know how much they don't
know with the pre-assessment test or
just with a little bit of training then
that makes them feel like it's relevant
as well the other thing is that you can
customize your course electric side with
the with the decision making exercises
like that applied learning but even more
so you can you can actually schedule
these elearning courses to coincide with
five checks that employees are doing so
that you can give the training right
before they will actually use those new
skills on the job for example if you're
good planning on integrating Salesforce
into your into your months you may not
want to have because there's a retention
problem if you feel learn if you go
through a course even if you get a
certification what you learn it you kind
of forget a lot of stuff if he was
basically if you haven't put it right to
work so one of the best things you can
do to make your training relevant is to
time it it's close to when you're gonna
need the skills as possible because if
you have everyone go through Salesforce
training and then you don't bring
Salesforce on board for six or nine
months then by the time they get to it
two things have happened they most
people have forgotten about it and
second of all Salesforce has added some
features that may not have been covered
in the original course and that's one of
the nice nice thing about simpler of
course is that our course experts
actually continually renew the courses
and keep it fresh so that's I think that
can help the relevancy a lot as well
that - Dan I think it's important
because if the closer you do it to the
training to actual projects and things
that work you're doing an application
piece and that's where you really can
understand if they're if they're truly
learning and applying it to work and I
think that's important yeah so what
about making the training social and
team oriented this is you've got this
great backward because you've been not
only doing doing coursework at the
university level but as it as a
principal and you're a math you're
science teacher weren't you I was I was
a science teacher and you know while I
try to keep soon attention you know
between six and eight grade they're not
always super intensive so you know I
occasionally would you know blow things
up or jump on a table and light things
on fire just so I could keep everyone
invested in what I was doing science it
was good for their attention span so I
think it was important but I think one
thing to note when you're ever you doing
any sort of training social and team
oriented training is so helpful live
student action always improve student
engagement and course completion rates
I'm telling you it's it's it's
way to do it luckily on-site
instructor-led classroom training isn't
the only way to take advantage of the
these interactiveness so you can achieve
this with online learning by creating
virtual teams which i've seen be very
successful or online learning
communities and by connecting some of
these lessons via live video
conferencing so i know a lot of times we
run into the idea of well if I can't do
it live is it gonna be as engaging yeah
if you do set this up right where you
have a virtual class or everyone is just
doing eLearning you can really still
harness all of that energy and kind of
bring people together at different
points by setting up these virtual
communities allowing people to you know
WebEx with each other and discuss it
those are ways to bring people together
whether they're near or far it makes it
really helpful yeah we have one question
in here someone's actually asking so is
there anything to show are there any
statistics that can demonstrate that
working in virtual teams is any more
effective than working alone I mean as
people looked at this I would imagine
they have they have actually there was a
study that was done in 2003 a gentleman
named Chuck easily he was an assistant
professor at Stanford University he was
able to find that students who worked in
virtual teams were actually 16 times
more likely to finish it so that's an
impressive number right there of the
23,000 577 students who worked
individually only 2 percent complete by
contrast of the 2600 71 students in
teams 32 graduate 32 percent graduated
so the same study showed that completion
rates are even greater 44% for teams
that had a virtual mentor present so yes
having that team orientation really does
their steps I back it up yeah and you
mentioned that mentor thing too we kind
of touched on that a bit having a mentor
looking over it even in a virtual way
will really ask to that help and you
know what also sort of helpful in a--
and i hate to say this next i did this a
lot with my students and i have also
seen that as adults myself was a learner
and myself as a teacher that we find
that there's this buddy system right so
if i have a friend that is completing
something in a course i
I actually want to keep up with them
there's a little bit of this like peer
pressure to continue to going but it's
also disloyalty because my friends going
to be talking about things that are
happening in the course that they're
going through I won't actually be part
of that conversation so that's another
great way when you're when you're
building this social or team or
environment you can't let them actually
play off of each other a little bit yeah
and you get that we have that phenomenon
here called FOMO which is a fear of
missing out and I know that you can when
when people are motivated by seeing what
other people are doing the third
finishing projects or if they see like
certificates or little awards that you
can give away to motivate people they
see people getting a little ribbon I
know this one place that that I work we
actually all went through first aid
training and that became very exciting
because we all got to get our little
first aid cards and we got a little
first aid patch that we would have and
when people would see that it go how'd
you get that so I went through the first
aid training and I'm sure that can help
a lot of other people too sure there
what else can managers do to kind of
develop that the team oriented kind of
fostered that team oriented energy well
you did mention something when you're
talking about the your patch the
certification is issuing even printed
certificates I've actually seen this
done and I think it is a really great
way to sort of build that excitement as
I've seen on certificates by the company
be made so that anytime people finished
either work within the course of the
course itself they were given
certificates the learners and they would
start putting them up and their cubes or
their offices and it's funny to watch
how people see what which certificates
are up and start working to get those
certificates I mean it's a really
amazing feeling to have anyone want to
be able to accomplish what other people
are doing that's important and simply
learn we have certificates of completion
and I have seen I've gotten to companies
where you know kind of walked around
with the learners and got the chance to
meet them and I've seen simply learn to
so if it gets up and I've actually heard
people say to me oh I'm almost done I'm
gonna get my - without me even saying
anything to it they just see me look at
the certificate and someone else will
comment on it so that does actually work
really well and it's not
expensive thing to do it's a very easy
thing also I find that just sending out
some emails some congratulatory emails
those go a long way one it shows a
little bit of value to the employee but
if you're sending an email out to the
team and you're saying hey I really want
to recognize these people for their you
know making the most progress this week
you will notice the next week that all
of a sudden you've got other people
making more progress because they want
to get in that piece and it's it's a
little bit of like a celebrity sort of
feeling right because I'm being
recognized by other people and you could
also just individually create a
celebrity by being let's say this is the
person that's working the hardest this
week or this is the person I've seen no
success for it so far on their
completion and that really helps build
up people to want to do more because
you're you're not necessarily being
negative to people that aren't doing it
you're really just highlighting those
that are doing it and it tends to build
people's own interest in value to want
to continue with it yeah I hear the term
gamification thrown around in e-learning
a lot is is that what this has to do
with you know it's a it's a bit of that
same idea right so if we're gonna be
doing things and kind of creating make
it a little bit competitive giving
badges maybe even posting a leaderboard
so we're doing leaderboards within
simply learn but I've also see companies
you know put lead a voice up on their
own well what's a leaderboard so a
little border be let's say you've got
everyone taking a specific course in a
group and the leaderboard is those that
are the furthest within the course right
or have seen leaderboards those that
have the highest quiz or a final test
scores so you start promoting those that
are getting further and it actually
starts to push the other people to kind
of keep moving and it could even be a
course completion as well how far
someone gets within a course right I
think another one too that helps is like
giving people reminders because I know
that was one of the biggest issues that
people have with not completing training
has been the fact that they'd simply
forgot about it but also give them
realistic deadlines players are busy and
they often get distracted and it makes
it easy to forget and continue or finish
your training courses that you've
started one of things you can do is have
an automatic reminder email campaign and
that can have a great effect on the
completion rates the
because it just reminds people to sign
in and get them started in the course
again deadlines also help to motivate
completion because you can offer
employees a bonus for completing the
training within a certain period of time
now when you establish deadlines you
just have to remember that if they make
it realistic a realistic target
completion date is important because
like in most case 30 days should be
ample time to explain of course but
there may be times when it takes makes
sense to even shorten the schedule if
the skills are gonna be required sooner
the expected completion date should be
synced with that timing requirement and
that comes up what we talked about
before where make your deadlines and
start the training actually closer to
when they're gonna need the skills also
I know it's helpful to have a learning
management system or some other type of
monitoring dashboard that makes it makes
it easy to alert managers to the fact
that someone's falling behind or not
signing up for the learning because in
the management could say hey get with a
program and as the deadline approaches
you can just gently remind employees
that haven't pleaded it that the
deadlines near and if necessary you can
grant extensions with with proper reason
and you can reflect those extensions in
the employees training records and that
kind of helps helps as well so and now
this is the big one let's talk about
rewards because that's the main thing
that gets people doing anything and that
is giving them a reward or some type of
incentive what are some things that
you've heard about robbery so I think
you know what's interesting is is aside
from doing things simple like creating
certificates which i think is a great
way to do those a lot of times a
recognition in general is just what's
really helpful right so it could be done
to being something as simple as giving a
you know a quick like a gift card to
something it could be something where
it's an email out it could be an
announcement at the team meeting all of
these different types of rewards are
available so if you're looking at you
know what's on the screen right now
we've got incentives and disincentives
and it really depends on what you know
matches best for your company
right and so I think you know you're
looking at the tangible you could do
something that actually relates to job
advancement that's where I was talking
about putting tech things into the kpi's
or annual goals because that actually
makes it very tangible for them to hang
on to and work towards and like we said
there is a there could be a financial or
a non-financial benefit and and so I
think there's a couple ways to look at
that I think another piece to look at is
disincentives and so you could actually
get to the point where you say hey you
know what if you're not going to take
this course seriously or take it you're
gonna be responsible for paying for it
and making them actually think about the
fact that they're gonna be paying the
fee to it because you know occasionally
we'll run into a situation where in b2b
world if you as a company are covering
the cost for things sometimes we don't
take it as seriously as if we're
actually putting the money on our own
pocket well that's great now and it
doesn't need to be expensive does it no
no no there's a million ways you could
do things you know even if it's just a
lunch for people it could be something
that simple it could be again a
certificate or an email that doesn't
cost anything at all there's a lot of
ways to make sure that you're you're
really recognizing the people and I
think as we start to do it you'll see
what resonates most of people and you
know people are gonna react differently
to different things but keep it open to
a lot of options for yourself
great cool so let's move on here about
now one thing that I kind of wanted to
talk about disincentives here because in
cases where there's kind of a risk of
something that's being used as the the
stick you hear about the carrot and the
stick
and you have to recognize that their
drawbacks to using more disincentives
because mandating training particularly
if the skills learned are outside the
scope of the employees original job then
that can really kind of build some
resentment now if it's part of their job
review I know
experts kind of recommend that you
should tell employees that will be
looked upon favorably in their review
rather than treating it as punishment if
they don't because the trouble with
penalties for less than stellar
performance is that they they often
build resentment and result in people
taking fewer risks and that stifles
creativity you don't want that in your
business
let's tell us a bit about certification
as an incentive how does that work so I
think you know there's a couple ways you
could be really doing it right because
if you want to set up external
certification by a third-party industry
respected organization it's a great
motivation motivator to complete the
training because they're actually
working towards that goal of completion
it also provides numerous benefits to
both the employee and the organization
so certification after training can you
know motivate during motivates during
the learning by providing a quantifiable
goal because they're working to get that
actual certification from that third
party it also improves retention of the
newly learned material because you know
that you're gonna need that to be able
to take that third party exam it can
also demonstrate to the learner that the
course is relevant because we're not
just saying hey let's take this course
we're saying let's take this course we
need you to be certified in something um
it also is going to validate the
employees expertise to colleagues and in
customers and that's a huge piece right
because if we want to make sure that not
that we want to you know be bright full
all the time but it's important to make
sure that we can validate our expertise
within our field and it's gonna improve
the employee satisfaction retention and
the employer reputation and finally it's
going to provide employees with a
valuable career advantage because they
can use that when they move on to their
next career and that's a really
important thing to think about because
it's not just a once and done it's a
certification that they have yeah those
are great ideas so well let's figure out
a plan for success like how can people
one of here's a step-by-step list of
things that you as a company can do to
really help ensure the completion of
your training one of those is provide
sufficient budget for development that's
one of the hardest things for a lot of
learning about people to come up with is
is a a reason for their training and one
of the cool things about measuring this
training is that you can develop an ROI
and demonstrate the return on investment
the other thing you can do is dedicating
ample time like we talked about for
employee training make sure you use
effective course design keeping them
short engaging units
and also providing the training
incentives that you just talked about
also making sure that managers
supervisors support the learners and
understand the learning process going on
and making it making the training
relevant through the customers content
and even applied learning projects you
can also provide employees with the
optimum technology that they need both
the terms in the software the hardware
for the training so that they are all on
the same page when it comes to doing
this not trying to fumble around on
different phones and give them the time
and the equipment to do it like on their
desktop even even ideally and if they
they have troubles with that and then
help them out and finally establish a
learning culture so now if there are any
other questions that have come up I just
want to give this while we're waiting
for the questions to roll in by the way
everyone is going to receive a email
that has a recording of this webinar so
you go through it again as well as the
white paper that a company is it and one
thing is you need to know is that CEOs
pulse' Vardy who's the who is the Human
Resources coach at our entrepreneur comm
said the CEOs should think of employee
development not as an expense but as an
investment because in today's economy if
your business isn't learning then you're
definitely gonna be falling behind and
just a little bit of an overview tell us
a little bit about in a nutshell about
how simply learning can can help that
take a step backward and this is coming
with my teacher and principal hat on is
because different people aren't best in
different ways it's helpful to use
multiple delivery methods including
online learning videos live online
training classroom learning and even
hands-on practice and role-playing that
this and that's a blended approach that
simply learn actually is offering and I
think you know you'd mentioned it
earlier than that because it does all of
those pieces it's actually the reason
why the completion rate is about 72
percent for our training services and
that's really important now I'm gonna
say there is no single silver bullet
when it comes to guaranteeing course
completion but you know applying many of
these proven methods I think are going
to
what helps make a training program
better more effective more enjoyable for
your employees and more applicable to
their jobs so keeping that in mind you
know simpler and does offer a lot of
these different media's to be able to
use and in the end you want to think
about what you're gonna get out of out
of it for your employee for your company
and also for the long run
great well those are some great
suggestions and I I'm gonna be happy
with sending we have a white paper that
details a lot of these more specifically
and we'll be sending a link to all of
the attendees thank you everyone for
joining us we have a few more minutes
for questions
you can also ping us for an email at
team training at simple urn comm
particular if you're interested in how
we can develop a course for you so with
that we'll just leave the questions open
for a little bit longer and yeah and
then wrap it up just to just a minute
here is there anything else you'd like
to throw it to the hopper Bob I just
reminded that if you're gonna answer any
ask any questions it sounded me on your
right-hand side that you can go ahead
and do that and just you know one last
piece to is just think of the fact that
if you were a manager there setting up
training you're a little bit like a
teacher trying to plan for a classroom
and so you want to make sure that you
really do think about what your learners
are gonna be like and it's dan mentioned
earlier make sure you're planning a
budget for really solid training you get
what you put into it so I think if I'm
not mistaken I read somewhere in Dan I
apologize I don't have the exact staff
for this but people spend should be
spending about or an average about
$1,200 a year on their employees for
training and to be honestly I don't know
that I see that is often you know what's
interesting that I saw the the budget
for training is now got up to it used to
be about nine hundred and forty three
dollars per student and now it's is
twelve hundred dollars per employee and
the the rise of of money spent in
employee training has actually double
the increased rate then the amount of
money spent on technology so
people are getting the clue that
training is important and one of the
cool things about that training is
they're finding that in in areas where
you have a hard time getting employees
to do those skills and that's it's an
expensive thing to hire people to do
something that you can just train
existing employees to do because not
only will you train an existing employee
that motivates them and that gives them
an extra skill and you don't have to
bother with the recruiting cost and and
you don't have to have that slow uptake
where they get developed into the
employee country culture they just
automatically are become much more
efficient right away so train your
employees to do the job is that you need
to have done as your company progresses
and you'll find that not only helps your
company but it helps your employees as
well so with that I think we're going to
wrap that up and check your emails
everyone in about a week or so you're
gonna get a message that has recording
of this webinar and also the
accompanying white paper - so on behalf
of myself and simpler and I wanna say
thank you all for joining us today
and Robert thank you for joining us
absolutely thank you for everyone and
thank you everyone and I hope you have a
great rest of your day good night and
good day
you